all right guys Dominic here for kick
Guru and today we are back with our
first look at a custom RX 7900 XTX
graphics card info review today is the
sapphire Nitro plus model featuring a
420 watt power limit a boost clock of
2680 megahertz and I must say a pretty
jaw-dropping design today then we're
gonna find out exactly how well this
card Stacks up against amd's reference
design looking at Thermals gaming
overclocking and more so without further
Ado let's Dive In
foreign
[Music]
starting with a look at the design of
the car then I do have to give Sapphire
big credit here this is without doubt
one of the best looking graphics cards
that I can remember Sapphire has opted
for a gray shroud that curves
beautifully around both ends of the card
before meeting the gray metal backplate
on top although made from plastic the
Shroud does feel pretty rigid in the
hand perhaps in part thanks to the
internal aluminum magnesium alloy that
Sapphire claims is designed to improve
structural stiffness a long RGB diffuser
can also be found on either side of the
Shroud and this is a new design feature
for the Nitro plus I have to say that
the RGB is very well done the light
itself is very evenly diffused with no
hot spots but it doesn't look overly
Gordy either Sapphire does also include
a 5 volt argb header on the card itself
so you can synchronize the lighting with
your motherboard though do note that for
this to work you need to download the
trick software and set the LED setting
to external Source a 4 pin pwm fan
header is even placed next to the argb
connection to allow a chassis fan to be
controlled based on the gpu's own fan
curve speaking of the fans we obviously
get three here and these use Sapphire's
angular velocity fan blade design with
the company claiming up to 19 more
airflow compared to the previous
generation each fan measures
approximately 98 millimeters across and
they continue to feature Sapphire's
Quick Connect feature so they can be
individually removed after taking out
just a single screw per fan we can't get
away from the fact that this is a big
graphics card though much bigger than a
and B's reference design the Nitro plus
measures in at 320 by
135.8 by 71.6 millimeters so it's pretty
low long and over three and a half slots
thick making it both longer and wider
than the RTX 4090 Founders Edition it
also weighs in at just under 1.94 kilos
flipping the card over then we can note
the gray metal backplate which perfectly
matches the color of the Shroud the back
plate itself doesn't quite extend to the
entire length of the card instead
leaving a small gap for airflow between
the end of the back plate and the
internal metal frame that wraps around
the end of the card we can also see that
a dual bio switch is placed on the back
of the card as well and this is very
close to the i o bracket technically
this is a three-way switch as the
setting furthest from the i o bracket
engages the primary bios the secondary
bios is in the middle and on the
furthest left sitting Sapphire includes
a software switch option and this simply
lets you change between the two bios
modes from within the trick software so
there's no need to physically move that
switch for the BIOS modes themselves
bios 1 has a 420 watt total board power
and it has a 2680 megahertz boost clock
while bios 2 which is the secondary bios
that has a lower 350 watt total board
power and a boost clock of 2 500
megahertz we can also note triple 8-pin
PCI power connectors so that's an extra
eight pin compared to reference while
Sapphire also includes two HDMI 2.1 and
two DisplayPort 1.4 video outputs in
terms of disassembly then we'll start
off by taking a look at the PCB here
Sapphire has opted for a 17 phase vrm
for the GPU and we can see a three-phase
vrm for the memory 70 amp Monolithic
Power Systems
mp87997 mosfets are used across the
board with the GPU vrm controlled by a
monolithic mp2857 and a monolithic
mp2856 controller is used for the memory
vrm as for the cooler than Sapphire has
brought back Vapor X for the Nitro plus
meaning a copper Vapor chamber is used
to directly contact the GPU and memory
modules while seven heat pipes draw heat
out into the finstack that aluminum
magnesium frame we already mentioned
does also serve a dual purpose as it
does contact the vrm to provide extra
cooling via some thermal pads Sapphire
also uses thermal pads on the underside
of the back plates though they are quite
thick at approximately four millimeters
so I'm not sure how much thermal
transfer there will be but I guess it's
better than nothing
foreign
[Music]
that is it for our look at the card
though so it's time to move on to
testing for this we are of course using
our regular GP test system for 2022
which is powered by MSI this is based on
Intel's I9 12900k CPU paired with the
MSI Meg z690 unified motherboard and 32
gigabytes of a data xpg Lancer ddr5
memory all testing was also done using
the MSI MBG 321 urqd 4k monitor kicking
off with film performance then as this
is the first aib card we've tested we've
not got any other comparison points
apart from the AMD reference design but
we can see that the Nitro plus bios one
mode does offer similar thermal
performance to the NBA design it is
important to note however that these are
out of the box thermal results so noise
levels are not taken into account bios 2
meanwhile runs about 5 degrees cooler
than by else one as a result of its
lower power limit these thermal results
look even better when we do take noise
levels into account the Nitro plus
operates at just 35 decibels so that's a
healthy six decibel reduction compared
to amd's reference card interestingly
noise levels are about the same between
bios 1 and bios 2 with both modes
peaking at 36 fan speed or around 1480
RPM in our testing I did however
unfortunately notice some coil wind
during my testing it's not the worst
I've ever heard but take a listen for
yourself with this quick sound test
foreign
normalized thermals to produce 40
decibels of Noise We had to increase fan
speed to 48 or about 1950 RPM this saw
the Nitro plus run comfortably cooler
than the AMD reference design offering a
7 degree reduction in terms of GPU
thermals but a 12 degree reduction when
looking at the hotspot this is also
while operating at a higher power limit
as well as noise normalized thermals
don't take power into account making the
overall design even more impressive
that's because Sapphire has actually
pumped up the power significantly with
the Nitro plus as we saw the car drawing
440 watts in our testing that does
however mean the overall efficiency of
the card is significantly reduced with
performance per watt down by 17 compared
to the reference card in cyberbank 2077
but let's take a look at what that means
in terms of the clock speed Headroom as
it turns out the extra power budget
afforded to the Nitro plus directly
translate into significantly raised
clock speeds bios 1 averaged
2751 megahertz over our 30 minute stress
test making it about 170 megahertz
faster than the reference design now
bios 2 does run noticeably slower as a
result of its reduced power limit but
even then overall performance closely
matches amd's reference card despite
that factory overclock though our game
benchmarks only show limited gains for
the Nitro plus when compared to amd's
reference design we saw at most a four
percent boost to frame rates in Horizon
zero Dawn but typically the figure was
just two percent as shown in cyberpunk
2077 and Resident Evil Village as ever
the factory overclock alone is not a
real reason to buy one card over the
other as the differences of very minor
finishing with a look at overclocking
lens if you've already seen our launch
day review of the 7900 XTX you will know
that we had very limited success here so
it was an area where I wanted to spend a
bit more time with the Nitro plus one
key change I made was adjusting the
voltage slider and undervolting really
does help with this GPU I lowered this
by 60 millivolts down from 1150 to 1090
millivolts while setting a maximum GPU
clock of 3050 megahertz the memory clock
was adjusted to
2720 megahertz with the power limit
maximized at plus 15 now this overclock
did actually net relatively decent gains
in our testing far better than what we
saw on launch day with improvements
coming in around eight percent above the
Nitro plus running its default settings
in some cases the 7900 XTX was not too
far off the RTX 1490 City though of
course it never fully caught up the
downside to pushing a custom card like
this to its limit is that power draw did
increase significantly we measured just
under 490 Watts power draw in cyberpunk
2077 at 4K though as you can see here we
even exceeded 510 watts in Resident Evil
Village considering this 7900 XTX was
still always slower than a stock RTX
4090 that is a heck of a lot of juice
after all of that then I think it's fair
to say the sapphire Nitro plus is one of
the best AMD based graphics cards that I
have reviewed over the last few years
for starters I really think that
Sapphire has nailed the design for me
the gray color looks fantastic and the
subtle curves and RGB light bar really
adds a level of sophistication the cool
also performs very well and granted we
can't say how much better or worse it is
than any other custom card as this is
our first aib review it still managed to
be seven degrees cooler than amd's
reference design while also drawing over
80 Watts more power so that is pretty
impressive there's also a solid dual
bios implementation reasonable
overcoming Headroom once you bring
undervolting into play and it is a very
quiet graphics card but just a touch of
coil wine that was present on my sample
the one thing giving me cause for
concern then is of course going to be
pricing while it is currently out of
stock here in the UK it launched at 1300
pounds making it actually a hundred
pounds more expensive than some RTX
4080s right now in the UK I have to say
this was a worry for me when the 7900
xdx first came out for me this GP you
absolutely has to be cheaper than the
RTX 4080 to offer any meaningful value
as good as Sapphire's design is if you
can get a 4080 offering similar overall
performance but with dlss and Superior
Ray tracing for a hundred pounds less
than well I just think these 7900 XTX
becomes very hard to justify to be clear
Sapphire's custom Nitro plus design is
absolutely fantastic but for me the 7900
XTX just cannot demand a price premium
over the RTX 4080 as just doesn't make
sense anyway guys that is going to do it
for this review so if you liked it
please do toss me a thumbs up and let me
know your thoughts on this card down in
the comments below please do like and
subscribe if you haven't already and why
not come carry on the conversation in
our Discord server which is linked in
the description while there you can also
find a link to our brand new merch store
where you can see a couple cool designs
on screen now and lastly if you're
feeling particularly generous you could
also consider backing us on patreon
that's it for this one though guys I'm
Dominic forkick Guru and I'll see you in
the next video
[Music]